algo tímidamente, sobre esta idea
de usar patrones y formas
para hacer un traje que redujera el riesgo de ataques,
y pensó que era una buena idea.
Lo siguiente fue una investigación conjunta
con apoyo del Gobierno del oeste de Australia.
Entonces hicimos 3 cosas clave.
La primera fue mapear las características
físicas de los ojos
de los principales tiburones predadores,
o sea, el tiburón blanco, el tigre y el toro.
Lo hicimos genéticamente
y también anatómicamente.
Lo siguiente fue entender
con un modelado informático,
qué puede ver ese ojo
según la profundidad, distancia,
condiciones de luz, y claridad del agua del océano.
Así, identificamos
dos características clave:
qué patrones y formas llevaría el usuario
para ocultarse o ser difícil de divisar en el agua,
y cuáles podrían aportar
el mayor contraste y a la vez la mayor
desintegración del perfil
para que no sea confundida con una presa
o alimento de tiburón.
Lo siguiente fue convertir esto
en trajes de baño que la gente se pusiera,
y para eso invitamos a Ray Smith,
surfista, diseñador industrial y de trajes de baño,
diseñó el logo original de Quiksilver,
para que se reuniera con el equipo científico
y usara esa ciencia
en un traje estético que la gente llevara puesto.
Este es uno de los primeros modelos.
Es lo que llamo un traje "no me comas".
Tiene esa idea de las bandas, (Risas)
tiene las bandas, muy visibles,
son perturbadoras,
y se diseñó para que el tiburón
no nos considere comida corriente,
e incluso para confundir al tiburón.
Y este está diseñado para usar con una tabla de surf,
con esa parte oscura del frente,
y es mejor sobre todo para la superficie.
donde la retroilimunación y mostrar una silueta
es un problema.
El segundo modelo es el traje de camuflaje,
que oculta al portador
en la columna de agua.
Este traje tiene 3 paneles,
para distintas condiciones.
Uno o más de ellos
serán como los espectros de reflexión
para desaparecer total o parcialmente,
dejando al resto
para crear un perfil perturbador en la columna.
Este es especialmente adecuado
para el buceo
o sea, a mayor profundidad.
Supimos que aquí teníamos
ciencia muy sólida.
Sabíamos que para destacar
había que llevar rayas,
y que si para camuflarse
tenía que ir así.
La prueba de fuego es
qué hacen los tiburones
ante estos patrones y formas.
Las pruebas de personas en trajes de baño
en el agua con tiburones
en un entorno natural
es más difícil de lo que parece.
(Risas)
Así que tenemos que usar un cebo,
para obtener el número
de muestras para conseguir pruebas científicas,
y con el cebo
cambiamos el comportamiento del tiburón.
No vamos a usar gente,
la ética nos impide incluso usar
figuras humanoides como cebo en el agua.
Aun así, empezamos el proceso de prueba
en enero de este año,
primero con tiburones tigre
y después con tiburones blancos.
Lo hicimos
con un tambor perforado lleno de cebo,
revestido de neopreno,
y luego pusimos dos cámaras estéreo subacuáticas
para ver qué hacía el tiburón con el cebo.
Y como usamos estéreo
podemos saber cuál es el tamaño del tiburón,
ángulo de entrada, velocidad de salida,
y su comportamiento,
de manera empírica más que subjetiva.
Como debíamos preservar el método científico,
teníamos un cebo de control
que era de neopreno negro
como el de un traje negro normal
contra lo que llamamos
cebo de tecnología SAMS.
Los resultados no solo fueron apasionantes,
sino muy alentadores.
Hoy les mostraré
dos de esos resultados alentadores.
Este es un tiburón tigre de 4 metros
interactuando con el cebo negro de control
que había encontrado
un minuto y medio antes.
El mismo tiburón había interactuado,
encontrado este cebo SAMS,
el cebo Elude SAMS,
unos ocho minutos antes,
y pasó seis dando vueltas, para cazarlo,
buscando lo que podía olfatear pero no ver
y esta es la última interacción.
Los blancos tienen más seguridad que los tigres,
y aquí está el tiburón blanco
con el cebo de control,
el de neopreno negro,
yendo directo hacia abajo,
subiendo
e interactuando.
En contraste con el cebo de tecnología SAMS,
este tiene rayas,
es más táctil,
investiga más,
es más ansioso
y es reticente a venir directamente e irse.
(Aplausos)
Es importante que las pruebas se hagan de forma independiente,
la UWA se encarga de ellas.
Será un proceso continuo,
sujeto a revisión por pares y a publicación.
Es importante que este concepto
se guíe por la ciencia.
Desde la perspectiva de Mitigación de Ataques,
llevamos licencias de biotecnología,
y como no hacemos trajes de baño,
damos las licencias y los hacen otros.
Es interesante
ver cómo es la tecnología SAMS
integrada en un traje y, para eso,
por primera vez, en directo, para el mundo,
(Risas)
puedo mostrar cómo es la adaptación biológica
la ciencia y el diseño en la vida real.
Demos la bienvenida a Sam, el surfista,
por aquí, ¿dónde estás, Sam?
(Aplausos)
Y a Eduardo.
Hola, amigo.
Hola.
Gracias, señores. (Aplausos)
¿Qué hemos hecho aquí?
Bueno, para mí, en vez de tomar una hoja en blanco
y usar la ciencia como herramienta de invención,
hemos prestado atención a las pruebas biológicas,
le hemos dado importancia
a la prueba anecdótica humana,
y hemos usado la ciencia como herramienta
de traducción,
traducción de algo que ya estaba allí
en algo que podemos usar en beneficio de la humanidad.
Pienso que esta idea de la ciencia
como herramienta de traducción más que de invención
puede aplicarse de forma más amplia que esta
en la búsqueda de la innovación.
Después de todo, los hermanos Wright,
¿descubrieron el vuelo tripulado
u observaron el hecho biológico de volar
y tradujeron eso mecánicamente, lo replicaron,
para que los humanos pudiéramos usarlo?
Y el traje de neopreno,
quién sabe cómo será su aspecto
de aquí a dos, cinco
o 50 años, pero con este nuevo pensamiento,
supongo que es poco probable
que sea meramente negro.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)